[Music]
[Applause]
Andrew Whitworth a Prime video Thursday
night football analyst the former Rams
offensive lineman and won a Super Bowl
when's the last time Sean McVay reached
out to you to come back and play
football
uh to come back and play football none I
think he knows I'm I'm done so we we've
had plenty of those conversations but
we've talked a lot of ball this season
and just being there for him and what's
been a really tough year for them okay
what advice do you give with an
offensive line that's had what 14
different looks to it
yeah 14 different starters uh it's been
NFL history as far as the injury numbers
it's unbelievable uh you know I think
it's more obviously I played in
Cincinnati as you well know Dan I I went
through some ugly Seasons uh before so
you know just being there for him and
saying hey man just just a good
conversation of where you're at in a
year or what what can be the mentality
and really what you're talking to the
team about because when you start to get
like this guys just start to lose
confidence and and just uh you know our
presence about them in the locker room
to where you feel down every day and you
feel like man can it can this keep
happening to us and so I think just
having those conversations of how do you
keep guys fired up to go out and compete
every week and keeping that mentality of
going out and being a competitor uh in
what's been man just an unbelievable
Year from an injury rate standpoint okay
but help me understand that when you
were with some bad Bengals teams and you
get to week 15 week 16. I know you get
paid but how how do you kind of get that
energy to you know hey here's another
game and let's go out and play great
football or at least try
you know I think it's really when you
start to find out you know who it is
that stays I mean I look at those
moments throughout my time in Cincinnati
and even in La after we had a couple
good years and then had a down year or
two you find out who the guys are that
you're like you know what this is the
guy that we want here and why we want
him here and we want him here for the
Long Haul because you'll see that the
guys who just can't handle not having
success and the guys that maybe maybe
are playing the game for different
reasons other than just going out and
competing they struggle in those moments
but the guys who love football they love
the opportunity to compete and go be
physical and trying to win and do their
job they're the ones that stick out in
these moments you'll find leaders you'll
find guys that'll be somebody you lean
on for the next four to five years
everything in between teamers special
teamers different things like that that
really become the nucleus of your team
in moments like this because I know for
myself in 2008 we were 018 lot in played
the Jacksonville Jaguars and I had a
moment with my team where we had to make
a stand against them and I got in a
fight actually with John Henderson he
got kicked out of the game him and I
both but that week I had given a speech
to them that I'd never lost in my career
and anywhere I'd ever been and in my
time in college and high school and I
wasn't going to accept being that way in
the pros and we go out in that moment we
have a great game against them him and I
get in this big moment he was the guy at
that time in the league and from that
moment on I was the captain of the
Cincinnati Bengals and so you can find
who your guys are you're going to lean
on in these moments if you're looking
the right way
give me the team that you have the most
confidence in and the least confidence
in as far as playoff teams
you know I think probably for me the
most confidence is is you know the
Philadelphia Eagles I mean you know
people talk about the weapons they have
and and how Jalen hurts has played which
has been exceptional but what I really
look at is when you combine those things
with Elaine Johnson and Jason Kelsey a
Brandon Graham A Fletcher Cox these guys
that have been in the moment who've been
there they've won it they've they've
experienced what December football is
about winning in the playoffs is about
and they're also just great leaders
great dudes that want to go out and do
exactly what we just talked about they
want to go fight and win no matter what
the situation is you add that to what
you have the skill positions and how the
quarterback's playing and how that
secondaries played for them and you've
got a really special football team that
not only get out talenting people
possibly but they got the right
mentality and demeanor as a football
team to go out and compete in the
biggest moments and I think for me
really if I look at a team that I don't
trust as much it's up there obviously
we've seen Tennessee fall off I think
the dolphins are tough because it's like
man they're so explosive offensively but
defensively they don't seem to you know
every week you can't seem to see
consistency in their ability to stop
people when they need to and I think in
playoff football we've seen it time and
time again you know you got to have some
defensive stand you got to have the
ability to stop people and keep people
from scoring to win these games because
no matter how the offensive goes you
know at some point in the game you have
to make those stands and I don't know if
I trust their defense in those moments
Steve Young talked about this that
you're and we just had Marcellus Wiley
on that when your career is over
part of you dies because that's been you
that's been your identity for you know
when you're growing up when you're in
high school when you're in college when
you're in the pros and then you get to
be like 32 or 33 and you suffer a death
did you go through that of I just part
of me just died now I move on and now
I'm this different person
yeah I think you really do uh I think
for me what's a little different is that
I was a part of Cincinnati for so long I
mean 11 years that I almost went through
that experience when I moved to LA
because I was unsure what that move was
going to be like I was a 35 year old
lineman like how long am I actually
going to play so I kind of went through
a lot of those emotions of everything
I'd ever known as an NFL player had just
changed and I'm moving my entire family
across the country and so there was a
lot of of kind of that feeling of a loss
or death in my mind when I met at that
transition and then I got reinvigorated
around being around Sean McVay in a
franchise that was locked into finding a
way to win and that was so exciting that
really this year when I retired I was
really at the end it's like hey I've
played as long as I can possibly play
this has really been a blast and I
couldn't be more appreciative of my time
as an LA Ram but I'm done I'm finished
and so there's a little bit of a time
where you realize man it's a big wheel
and it keeps turning whether you're in
it or not I remember having those
conversations with Larry Fitzgerald this
summer where he just talked we kind of
both shared about different struggles we
had retiring and when you realize man
you were this guy and now even
relationships that you had that you talk
to people every day in your building
um you don't talk to hardly any anymore
just because they're in the middle of
everything that's going on in an NFL
year and and you're not so it's just
hard to have communication and feel
appreciated and feel a part of things
and you have to really come to grips
that like you know what this is this big
NFL machine and when you're not in it
man it just keeps rolling and I think
it's just that humbling feeling and once
you get used to it and realize hey I got
to find my identity in new ways you
start to embrace it in a better way
great to talk to you how's the
transition been you've uh have any
moments where you're like what am I
doing
yeah I'm not gonna lie to you Dan the
first time that camera turned on and
they're like you're live go I'm like you
know my heart's racing a thousand miles
an hour and I'm like man am I a rookie
facing you know Terrell Suggs again uh
what's going on right now and so you
know what it's finding a new way to be
challenging yourself it's been a lot of
fun I think for me then just like
studying the game is a left tackle it
was so much about the defense and my guy
had to block every play and now they
have the opportunity to study but more
nervous more nervous going on TV the
first time or playing in your first NFL
game
I want to say probably for me it would
be uh plain for sure because Carson
Palmer was back there and they just gave
him a whole lot of money so if he got
hit I was gonna be in a lot of trouble
going on
I don't have any problem talking so I'm
all right with that uh Merry Christmas
to you great to see you again and uh my
best to the Thursday night crew thank
you I appreciate it brother that's uh
Andrew Whitworth he's uh there with
Carissa Thompson Tony Gonzalez Ryan
Fitzpatrick Richard Sherman on site Jags
Jets tomorrow night